В ефірі новини «heute» з Яною Парайґіс.
Добрий вечір! Наступні десять хвилин - новини.
Про спортивні перемоги та поразки
вам розповість Норберт Леман.
Вітаю вас!
Тож до наших головних тем:
Росія визнала, що завдала ракетного удару
по Одеському морському торговому порту.
Схема обміну танками не працює,
тому партія Зелених вимагає прямого постачання
бронетехніки в Україну.
Неочікуваний п’єдестал -
німецька жіноча команда завоювала бронзу в естафеті
на Чемпіонаті світу з легкої атлетики в США.
В українських портах триває підготовка до експорту
мільйонів тонн зерна.
Втім, після ракетного обстрілу Одеси,
який Росія вже визнала, в Україні стурбовані,
що Росія не зацікавлена у дотриманні зернової угоди,
що буде викликати затримку експорту.
Про ситуацію після п'яти місяців війни
дивіться у репортажі Томаса Гонсіора.
Одеса, літній день війни.
Купатися та плавати в морі -
все це небезпечно для життя.
Попередження про морські міни.
Додається ще й загроза з повітря,
вчора стався обстріл порту.
Щонайменше один корабель згорів.
Українська сторона заявляє про напад на
транспорт для перевезення зерна.
Росія ще вчора заперечувала ракетний обстріл,
але сьогодні Москва все-таки
взяла відповідальність на себе.
Однак запевнивши, що вони поцілили у зброю,
а не пшеницю.
Збройні сили РФ точними ракетами
з акваторії Чорного моря вразили
український військовий корабель та
склад протикорабельних ракет Гарпун,
які було доставлено зі США.
Важливий порт зазнав обстрілу
наступного дня після підписання
експортної угоди щодо зерна із Росією.
Попри це Україна готується транспортувати зернові.
Міністр закордонних справ Росії,
відвідавши саміт Ліги арабських держав
у Єгипті, запевнив,
що така важлива для світової продовольчої системи
угода і надалі буде виконуватись.
Росія, Туреччина та ще одна країна будуть супроводжувати
конвої до проток для здійснення контролю.
Президент України не вірить у ці заяви.
Вчора Зеленський заявив:
Якщо хтось у світі раніше ще мігговорити,
що потрібен діалог з Росією,
якісь домовленості,
ви бачите, що російські ракети
руйнують усі домовленості.
Водночас Зеленський впевнений у перемозі.
Рівно п'ять місяців тому почалася війна.
Хоча проросійські сили завоювали певні території
на Сході України,
потроху просуваючись протягом двох місяців.
Але на півдні біля міста Херсон
українські війська звільняють території.
Одеса, літній день,
151 день війни з початку російського вторгнення.
Щойно ми отримали наступну новину:
міністр Лавров заявив, що метою
спеціальної військової операції,
так в Росії називають війну проти України,
є зміна режиму в Києві.
Президент України знову
вимагає збільшення постачання
важкого озброєння з-за кордону.
В Німеччині зʼявляється все більше прихильників
прямої передачі зброї, зокрема танків,
українському війську.
Отже, уникаючи покрокової передачі техніки
східним партнерам НАТО,
оскільки це дуже сповільнює процес,
а Україна не може гаяти час.
Детальніше про це Зімон Пфанцельт.
Танкоремонтний підрозділ української армії
не перестає працювати.
Завжди щось десь ламається.
Зламався гусеничний рушій або
розрядився акумулятор.
Армія працює на межі своїх можливостей.
Зелені зараз вимагають збільшення
прямого постачання зброї з Німеччини.
Ми маємо передати все можливе,
щоб Україна мала в достатній кількості все,
що їй зараз необхідно.
Ми обіцяли, що хочемо допомагати Україні,
якомога довше та всім, чим зможемо.
Потрібно переосмислити цей процес.
Схема покрокової передачі,
запропонована федеральним урядом,
поки не працює.
За планом східні партнери по НАТО,
Польща та Чехія,
мали передати старі радянські танки Україні.
Так це і сталось.
Натомість Німеччина повинна була
оснастити ці країни сучасною зброєю,
а ось це поки не вдалося.
З’явилась інформація, що Німеччина
передасть Польщі 20 танків Leopard 2.
Але з квітня 2023 року.
Спочатку по одному на місяць.
Реакція була недипломатично різкою.
Обіцянки німців про обмін танками виявилися
обманним маневром.
Заявив заступник міністра закордонних справ Польщі.
Нам запропонували символічну кількість танків.
Важко сприймати це як серйозну пропозицію,
адже ми за два місяці поставили в Україну
понад 200 танків.
Передача із запасів Бундесверу неможлива,
принаймні так запевняють в Міністерстві оборони.
Обговорення тривало з підприємствами ВПК.
Опозиція звинувачує владу в недотриманні обіцянок.
Якщо федеральний уряд
не хоче передавати цю зброю,
тоді нехай вони скажуть про це прямо.
Але вони не можуть спочатку обіцяти щось публічно,
а потім просто забувати про свої обіцянки.
Поки в Німеччині тривають дискусії
щодо постачання зброї,
Україна очікує на необхідну допомогу.
Лідер партії CDU Фрідріх Мерц
у своєму «літньому інтерв'ю ZDF»
дистанціювався від заяв свого соратника по партії
прем'єр-міністра Саксонії, Міхаеля Кречмера.
Кречмер наполягав на тому, що Німеччина
може стати посередником
між Росією та Україною,
щоб, цитую, «ця війна була заморожена».
Що Фрідріх Мерц розповів
про війну в Україні та її наслідки
дізнаєтесь в інтерв’ю Патриції Відемейєр.
Це його батьківщина, його виборчий
округ - Вінтерберг у Зауерланді.
Тут ми провели «літнє інтерв’ю» з головою CDU
Фрідріхом Мерцем.
Звісно, йшлося про наслідки війни в Україні,
майбутнє енергетичного сектору -
неможливість відмови від ядерної енергетики
у разі відмови від російського газу.
Я також прогнозую, що до кінця року ми побачимо,
як термін експлуатації АЕС буде продовжено.
Ми запропонували це федеральному уряду,
але пропозицію було відхилено.
Якщо звісно федеральний уряд хоче серйозно
поговорити із нами,
що вони зараз не роблять,
не зважаючи на наші пропозиції.
Однак, ми не будемо бігати за урядом.
Світлофорна коаліція зараз несе повну
відповідальність за вирішення цієї проблеми.
Але Мерц визнає,
що CDU теж робила помилки останні 16 років.
Я розумію відповідальність за те,
які рішення CDU тоді приймала.
Звісно, ми ці рішення обговорюємо.
Ми знаємо, що ми робили помилки,
але ми ніколи не були самі.
12 із 16 років ми були в коаліції з соціал-демократами.
Але й всередині партії постає багато спірних питань.
Наприклад, відносини з Росією,
запровадження жіночої квоти
або обмеження швидкості.
Втім, Мерц так не вважає:
Обмеження швидкості - символічна тема.
Ми б не вирішили цим ні екологічні,
ні транспортні проблеми.
Оцінка минулого та погляд у майбутнє показує,
що перед партією постає багато викликів,
тож є над чим працювати.
Повну версію «літнього інтерв'ю» з Фрідріхом Мерцем
дивіться відразу після нашого випуску «heute»
та у додатку «ZDFheute».
Посеред літньої хвилі коронавірусу
триває суперечка між міністром охорони здоров'я
та головою асоціації лікарів Гассоном.
Він ставить під сумнів необхідність
другої бустерної дози вакцини
та критикує рішення уряду,
замовити кілька видів вакцин на цю осінь.
Міністр Лаутербах рекомендує
другу бустерну дозу
і відкидає звинувачення щодо закупівлі вакцин.
Він заявив, що уряд вирішив закупити декілька препаратів,
тому що зараз ще невідомо,
який з них виявиться найкращим восени.
Папа Франциск в Twitter назвав це
подорожжю примирення:
голова католицької церкви вранці прибув до Канади,
де почалась його шестиденна поїздка.
Проте він пересувається у колісному кріслі
через біль у колінах.
Завтра він хоче зустрітися з корінним населенням,
щоб попросити пробачення за насильство у притулках,
що підтримувала католицька церква.
До 90-х у Канаді близько
150 000 дітей корінного населення
були розлучені зі своїми родинами і
розміщені в спеціальних закладах.
На півдні Європи тривають пожежі,
наприклад, у Греції.
На острові Лесбос вогонь практично безперешкодно
поширювався через дуже сухий ґрунтовий покрив.
Спроби пожежників вгамувати полум’я
виявились практично марними.
Пляжі, декілька будинків і машин
були знищені полум’ям.
Цілим містам довелося евакуюватись.
Ми переходимо до новин
з чемпіонату світу з легкої атлетики в США,
Норберте, нарешті Німеччина здобула медаль!
Так, в передостанній день змагань,
ми так довго на це чекали!
Бронзова медаль стала справжнім сюрпризом.
На медаль у естафеті 4 по 100 метрів серед жінок
ніхто не розраховував.
Четверо німецьких спринтерок досягли своєї мрії:
вони здобули бронзу на чемпіонату світу
за свій фантастичний виступ в естафеті.
Сьогодні удача була на нашому боці,
ми дуже чекали цього.
Це ніби сон.
Сподіваюсь, що я зараз не прокинусь.
Поруч із головними фаворитками зі США та Ямайки
німецька команда показала чудову форму.
Тетяна Пінто передає
естафетну паличку Александрі Бургардт.
Британці відстають через проблеми.
Гіна Люкенкемпер бореться і
Ребекка Гаасе рветься вперед у фінальному спринті.
Результат у 42,03 секунди та сльози радості.
Суперником Німеччини у
півфіналі чемпіонату Європи з футболу
в цю середу все ж стає Франція.
Ева Періссе забила гол на 102 хвилині.
Це був єдиний та вирішальний гол
у грі проти діючих чемпіонок Європи -
збірної Нідерландів.
Це перший вихід жіночої збірної Франції з футболу
до півфіналу чемпіонату Європи.
Макс Ферстаппен з Нідерландів переміг
у Гран-прі Франції.
Гонщик команди Red Bull Racing
відсвяткував свою сьому перемогу в сезоні
і зараз випереджає Шарля Леклера на 65 очок.
Пілот Ferrari стартував з поул-позиції,
але через помилку потратив в аварію.
Себастьян Феттель на Aston Martin фінішував 11-м.
Повернення через 13 років на
Тур де Франс серед жінок.
Нідерландка Лорена Вібес завоювала жовту майку.
На першому етапі в Парижі
23-річна спортсменка перемогла у протистоянні
проти своєї землячки Маріанни Восс
та бельгійки Лотти Копецкі.
Найкращою німецькою спортсменкою стала
колишня чемпіонка світу Ліза Бреннауер на 19 місці.
За кілька хвилин данець Йонас Вінгегард
святкуватиме свою перемогу серед чоловіків
в Гранд Турі на Тур де Франс в Парижі.
На цьому все.
Дякую тобі, Норберте!
Переходимо до погоди:
зі сторони Північного моря сильні зливи,
які переходять у грози з поривчастим вітром.
В інших регіонах погода приємна та сонячна,
температура сягне 25°С - 36°С.
О 21:45 Вульф Шмізе чекатиме на вас
у випуску «heute journal»!
Відразу після нашого випуску дивіться
«літнє інтерв'ю» з лідером CDU Фрідріхом Мерцем.
Гарного вечора!